der Löwe ist los so habe ich auch noch
keine Sendung begonnen aber alles kann
einen Anfang haben und damit herzlich
willkommen bei ZDF heute live
tatsächlich sind mit dieser Meldung der
Löwe oder die Löwin ist los heute einige
in Berlin südlich davon wach geworden
denn die Polizei geht davon aus dass im
Süden Berlins im Norden Brandenburgs
eine Löwin oder ein Löwe sein oder ihr
Unwesen treibt und ein Sprecher der
Polizei Direktion hat entsprechend dazu
gesagt wir können mal eine Kuh von der
Straße holen oder auch mal ein Pferd
einfangen aber die Jagd nach Wildkatzen
ist er ungewöhnlich auch im Land
Brandenburg und mit diesem
ungewöhnlichen Fall wollen wir uns
beschäftigen dieses Wildtier ist also
entlaufen momentan gibt es ein Video
davon das ist das was Zeugen aufgenommen
haben können wir uns jetzt auch mal
anschauen und nach allem was man bisher
weiß und was man darauf sieht gehen
Experten davon aus es könnte eine Löwin
sein aber ihr seht selbst das sind die
Bilder und das ist der dabei und
Spielraum den man hat daraus zu lesen
und zu sehen tja ist es eine Löwin oder
nicht aber viel spricht dafür auf jeden
Fall nimmt die Polizei das alles sehr
ernst und ist mit einem groß Aufgebot
vor Ort wir wollen darüber reden ihr
könnt wie immer eure Kommentare und
Fragen stellen an die eingeblendete
Adresse beginnen wir aber da in
Kleinmachnow südlich von Berlin bei
unserer Reporterin Stefanie Hein hallo
Stefanie
hallo ja ich sag das gerade die Polizei
ist mit einem massiven Aufgebot vor Ort
umgekehrt kann man sich das glaube ich
nicht so vorstellen das würden da jetzt
Hundertschaften durch die Straßen ziehen
erzähl uns erstmal was passiert da
gerade
also durch die Straßen ziehen hier
tatsächlich keine Hundertschaften die
die Polizei warnt dass man nicht in die
Wälder gehen soll weswegen wir auch hier
ganz in der Nähe des Rathauses und nicht
irgendwo im finsteren Wald stehen denn
sie gehen schon davon aus dass das
irgendwo eine Löwin ist aber hier im Ort
merkt man nicht so viel es gab zwar die
Meldung dass die Leute eher zu Hause
bleiben sollen und und nicht draußen
spazieren gehen sollen aber immer
innerhalb der der Ortschaft scheint die
Gefahr für viele nicht besonders groß zu
sein also hier laufen ganz normal die
Menschen über die Straßen ich habe auch
einen gesehen der seinen Hund ausführte
und da ist
da ist die Aufregung nicht so groß aber
es wird wie verrückt gesucht es war bis
eben hier noch ein Hubschrauber zu hören
der ist jetzt gerade im Moment nicht
mehr da die Polizei hat gerade bekannt
gegeben dass sie immer noch mit wirklich
vielen Einsatzkräften suchen und auch
womöglich mit Drohnen unterwegs sind
habe ich schon gehört
also da das wird schon extrem ernst
genommen und es wird volle Kraft gesucht
nach eben einer Löwin wir haben die
Bilder gesehen den Hubschrauber in der
Luft aber eben auch Polizeiwagen
unterwegs es gab auch eine Warnung mit
der App wie genau funktioniert das und
wen hat das betroffen
also die ich ich wohne nicht in
Brandenburg ich wohne in Berlin und die
App hat auch mich erreicht heute morgen
das war das erste was ich sage Löwe los
und ich war mir nicht ganz sicher ich
habe glaube ich erstmal sehr sehr
geschmunzelt weil sowas das die App sagt
man hat hier ein freilaufendes Wildtier
dass man sucht sowas ist schon sehr
ungewöhnlich normalerweise kommt da was
von Unwetter
also diese diese diese Warnung über die
waren App hat also die Berliner und auch
die die Brandenburger erreicht die
Polizei ist wohl hier auch mit
Lautsprecherwagen rumgefahren und um
dazu aufzufordern doch eher zu Hause zu
bleiben aber es geht auch eben auch
darum dass man nicht gerade im Wald
joggen geht und weil da ist man glaube
ich dann schon ziemlich nah an der
möglichen Gefahr man muss es tatsächlich
ernst nehmen ich habe es vorhin auch
gesagt die erste Reaktion ist man
schmunzelt ein bisschen man mag es nicht
so recht glauben und doch die Gefahr ist
ja präsent sonst würde die Polizei das
ja auch nicht in der Form so propagieren
wir werden auch gleich noch mit Experten
sprechen die uns was über Gefahren dazu
sagen werden ein Löwe oder eine Löwin
die sich sozusagen auch in die Engel
getrieben fühlt wie man da vorgeht aber
der Reihe nach was passiert jetzt gerade
also es gibt keine Ausgangssperre aber
es gibt diese Warnung was heißt das
Spaziergänge vermeiden wie ist die
Gegend da bei dir überhaupt ist das sehr
städtisch geprägt oder doch schon sehr
ländlich
also kein machnow ist schon ein
Städtchen das ist jetzt keine große
Stadt das ist ein ist eine kleine Stadt
die ist auch sehr sehr grün es gibt
Parks rundherum und Kleinmachnow ist so
an der Stelle wo Berlin im Süden endet
dann kommt noch Kleinmachnow und danach
fängt das große grüne Brandenburg an
hier ist schon viel viel Grün ähm Wälder
und Felder und jede Menge Plätze wo man
sich glaube ich als Löwin sehr gut
verstecken kann
innerhalb innerhalb der Stadt ist das
jetzt nicht so dass das hier aussieht
wie ein großes Dorf das ist schon ein
richtiges Städtchen und das hier eine
Löwin durch dieses Städtchen spaziert
das wäre glaube ich noch mal eine ganz
andere Nummer als als in den in den
umliegenden Wäldern hier es wurde auch
tatsächlich schon gewitzelt es gab ja
ähm den Hinweis dass die Löwen
möglicherweise ein Wildschwein erlegt
hat und wenn es denn so gewesen wäre und
sie hätte dieses Wildschwein verputzt
dass sie das macht was Löwen machen
nämlich keinen Mittagsspaziergang
sondern Mittagsschläfchen das wird auch
zu beobachten sein wo und wie man dieses
Tier finden wird ein Wort noch gerade
dazu bevor wir dann gleich weitermachen
mit den Experten ist es denn
grundsätzlich verboten überhaupt einen
Löwen zu halten
da sind die Regeln im ganzen
Bundesgebiet tatsächlich nicht wirklich
einheitlich ein Löwen in Berlin zu
halten das wäre als Privatperson
definitiv verboten da gibt es ein Gesetz
was ich mit diesen gefährlichen Tieren
beschäftigt und das ist in Berlin nicht
erlaubt da fallen zum Beispiel auch
giftige Schlangen drunter und eben auch
Raubkatzen in Brandenburg gibt es so ein
Gesetz nicht da greifen also nur
übergeordnete Gesetze etwa zum zum
Artenschutz und
und zum zum Tierschutz allgemein das
heißt es wäre im Grunde erlaubt wenn man
sich an Punkte hält zu denen artgerechte
Tierhaltung groß genug groß genug Stall
und eben auch Sicherheit hält und was
wir jetzt sehen können wenn das ein Löwe
ist der hier unterwegs ist hat das mit
der Sicherheit auf jeden Fall schon mal
nicht geklappt Stefanie Heim vielen Dank
für den Moment vielleicht sprechen wir
nachher noch mal weiter wir gucken wie
sich das in den nächsten Minuten
entwickelt aber danke für den Moment
danke Stefanie
schauen wir dahin wo dieser Löwe
möglicherweise herkommt und insofern
wurden auch die Zoos Zirkus etc gefragt
dort in der Nähe sag mal fehlt euch
vielleicht ein Löwe oder eine Löwin
bisher war die Antwort nein aber gehen
wir diese Frage erstmal weiter an
Christian Kern das ist der zoologische
Direktor vom Tierpark Berlin guten Tag
ich nehme an sie haben ihre Löwinnen und
Löwen gezählt oder das haben wir heute
und alle da und auch das noch zu fragen
ich höre sie gerade nicht denn fragt man
die Regie ob es sozusagen ein jetzt
glaube ich geht es wieder sagen sie noch
mal was
genau also wir haben sofort alle Tiere
gezählt das tun wir jeden Morgen das ist
standardroutine bei uns ein Teil der
Sicherheitsprotokolle
es ist ja noch nicht eindeutig ob es
sich wirklich um einen Löwen oder Löwen
handelt wir haben vorhin mal dieses
Video gesehen das sieht danach aus haben
Sie eine Meinung schon dazu aus ihrer
professionellen Sicht ist es eine
das ist es in der Tat schwierig zu
beurteilen des Videos ja fragmentartig
und auch verschwommen wir haben das auch
intern im Haus versucht auszuwerden auf
den ersten Blick sieht es aus wie eine
Löwen wir können das also wieder
bestätigen aber wir können es auch nicht
entkräften es vielleicht ist es auch zu
10 % wahrscheinlich
aber es ist sehr wahrscheinlich eine
große Katze und das ist
entscheidend durch wie gefährlich ist so
ein Tier
das kommt auf den Kontext auf die
räumliche Situation tatsächlich an also
wenn Sie sich wenn Sie das Tier sehen
oder begegnen auf großen
Park
fällt oder auf großen Straßensituation
hat das hier in der Regel Angst das ist
eine Stresssituation weil es ja endlich
ist aus einer anderen Umgebung als eine
gebunden Umgebung und damit hat das ja
erstmal Angst und der erste Reflexe sich
zurückzuziehen das sucht also nicht
aktiviert dass Menschen die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass so ein Löwe in
einer so eine römischen Situation
wirklich angreift das ist relativ gering
wenn er wirklich in die Siedlungen und
mehr ein städtische Gebiet gehen sollte
dann muss man etwas schauen dass man ihn
nicht zufällig ungewollte in einem
Hinterhalt begegnen also in einem
Schuppen in der Garage oder vielleicht
auch in dem Stall mit sieben oder
Schafen das hängt auch ein bisschen
damit zusammen wie das hier vielleicht
auch aufgewachsen ist das mit der Hand
aufgezogen werden
mal danach zu fragen also was macht so
ein Tier denn überhaupt erstmal
gefährlich ist es die ist es der Stress
den es gerade erlebt ist es das
ungewohnte ist es eine mögliche
Begegnung mit einem Menschen oder was
ist sozusagen aus ihrer Sicht das was
jetzt erstmal zählt
auf einer großen Fläche wo das Tier
flüchten kann besteht nur eine sehr
geringe Farbe das ist angreifen wird und
wenn es angreift das ist einfach die die
körperlichen Kräfte die Menschen nicht
standhalten können
[Musik]
und dann ist es immer dem wie das Tier
wirklich auch konditioniert ist
aufgewachsen wie groß ist kann das auch
wirklich werden aber das ist eher sehr
sehr geringer Wahrscheinlichkeit
weil wir vorhin darüber gesprochen haben
dass es warn-appsmeldungen gab etc und
um auch hier glaube ich noch mal die die
Dringlichkeit klar zu machen was heißt
das jetzt für die Bewohner dort in der
Gegend was ist aus ihrer Sicht jetzt
wirklich dringend angeraten
in eine räumliche Situation mit dem Tier
zu kommen aus welchen Gründen auch immer
wenn dann wird es sich ein Rückhalt
sehen
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist bewegt sich ja
offensichtlich
flüchten das ist das entscheiden das
wird also so keine Motivation haben das
Tier auf sie zuzugehen das heißt sie
halten auch Abstand versuchen das was
man Entfernung von mindestens 40 50
Metern weiter zu beobachten die Polizei
anzurufen und den Standort durchzugeben
weil diese Zufalls Beobachtung durch
Leute Bevölkerung hat wahrscheinlich die
höchste Chance dass man wieder den Faden
aufnehmen kann das jetzt zu finden
mal ins praktische gefragt und nicht
dass man sich das vorstellen mag aber
wenn man vor einem Löwen steht oder
zumindest nicht allzu weit weg von ihm
ist was mache ich dann was lasse ich was
tue ich auf keinen Fall was ist
angeraten es kommt auch wieder auf den
auf den räumlichen Kontext an was ist
das wirklich eine Situation das ist so
so abhängig davon in welcher räumlichen
Situation man sich gerade befindet wenn
es jetzt wirklich eine Garage wäre was
unwahrscheinlich ist dann würde ich die
Tür zu machen und weggehen tatsächlich
wenn es irgendwo im Wald ist so wie auf
diesem Video zum Beispiel dann kann man
mit geeigneten Abstand einfach sich
zurückziehen oder mit Abstand auch
weiter beobachten
wenn oben da fragt wir Facebook wo
könnte der Löwe denn mittlerweile sein
wie weit bewegen sich Tiere in an einem
Tag
zu sagen wenn wir auch nicht wissen wie
wohl fühlt er sich in diesem Beispiel
zum Beispiel wie lange wir wissen nicht
wann er endlich ist vielleicht ist er da
schon ein paar Tage oder Wochen ohne
dass das beobachtet wurde das ist schwer
zu sagen aber kann sich natürlich viele
viele Kilometer bewegen und unter
Umständen auch Kilometer das kommt auf
die Motivation drauf ein wenn er sich da
nicht wohl fühlt wenn er keine Nahrung
findet natürlich weiterziehen fühlte
sich da irgendwie wohl und geboren und
geschützt und findet auch ein bisschen
Nahrung und sei es dann kann er da auch
Standort bleiben
Dave alright fragte über Youtube wie man
jetzt so ein Tier einfangen kann und wie
man da vorgeht am besten hoffentlich mit
mit Betäubung oder was ist das was jetzt
da angeraten ist und wie man sich
aufstellt
das ist keine einfache Frage tatsächlich
aus unserer Sicht gibt es drei Optionen
das erste ist eine sehr sehr große
nebenfalle die so erstmal nicht
verfügbar ist zumindestens heute nicht
auch das ist ein Prozess der viele viele
Wochen wahrscheinlich in Anspruch nehmen
würde das zweite ist dass man
Narkosegewehr also eine
distanzimmobilien versucht auch das hat
seine Grenzen weil so eine Narkose wäre
nur 50 bis 75 Meter ungefähr erreicht
und es kommt darauf die Windverhältnisse
an und auf die Decke dazu tatsächlich
auch wieder sehr stark an den räumlichen
Gegebenheiten vor Ort abhängig und das
dritte ist letztlich die Schafe
ich nehme mal an sie haben täglich viel
Arbeit damit ihre Tiere entsprechend
nicht nur dort zu betreuen und auch zu
füttern natürlich sondern ihnen auch das
bestmögliche Umfeld zu bieten das ist ja
nicht unbedingt immer gegeben und wenn
sie jetzt so einen Fall wie diesen hören
was sind die Gedanken die ihnen da
kommen
Gedanken die einem kommen ist ja
hoffentlich gelingt es allen Beteiligten
Verantwortlichen das Tier ohne
ohne es zu erschießen zu müssen
letztlich was immer mit der Sicherheit
des Menschen zusammenhängt was an erster
Stelle steht
eingefangen zu bekommen
ich danke ihnen erstmal dass sie zur
Verfügung standen und uns diese
Information gegeben haben und hoffen
tatsächlich auch dass das alles gut und
glimpflicht ausgeht danke für Ihre Zeit
ziehen wir mal eine kurze Zwischenbilanz
bevor wir weiter reden was es alles auch
im privaten Sektor noch dazu zu sagen
und zu wissen gibt denn Löwen sind nicht
nur in Zoos oder Tierparks zu Hause
sondern eben durchaus auch schon mal den
privaten reden wir gleich drüber machen
aber jetzt einmal noch einen
Zwischenschnitt und gucken auf das was
wir im Moment wissen und auch wie die
ersten Reaktionen zu diesem entlaufenden
Löwen dort in der Gegend sind
Aufregung seit heute Nacht rund um
Kleinmachnow südwestlich von Berlin die
Polizei ist mit Hubschraubern und
Einsatzwagen vor Ort ebenso bewaffnete
Jäger um 2 Uhr morgens war dieses Video
eines Raubtiers in den sozialen Medien
aufgetaucht vermutlich eine Löwin so die
Polizei nach jetzigen Stand wird eine
Löwin aber weder in Zoos noch im Zirkus
vermisst über eine warn-app und im Radio
warnen die Behörden vor dem Verlassen
der eigenen Wohnung
mit dem Fahrrad auf dem Weg zur Arbeit
und soll jetzt hier an der Stelle nicht
mehr weiterfahren weil sie eine
freiläufende freilaufende Löwin in den
Bereich geben soll also ich losgelaufen
bin habe ich zwei Polizeihubschrauber
immer klein machen nur gehört die
gekreist haben und dann bin ich gelaufen
einmal meine Runde und als ich hier
vorne angekommen bin wurde ich sofort
von der Polizei Streife angehalten immer
gesagt haben dass hier ein wildes Tier
wollen Löwe sich im Wald befindet sofort
ab nach Hause und
am besten zu Hause bleiben ich durch die
Polizei die hier steht fühle ich mich
eigentlich gar nicht unsicher genau eine
Nachbarin hat den wohl auch gesehen der
hier hinter zum stolperberg gelaufen ist
aber genau wir fühlen uns eigentlich
jetzt nicht unsicher klingt irgendwie
alles so ein bisschen unglaublich also
unglaublich irgendwie eher so ein Löwe
draußen auf der Straße oder hier im Wald
das ist weiß ich nicht
mit der Wärmebildkamera eines
Hubschraubers wird die Umgebung
abgesucht die Polizei rief die Menschen
dazu auf achtsam zu sein und etwas
Spaziergänge in Wäldern zu vermeiden
eine Ausgangssperre gebe es aber nicht
wir haben zwar die Kindergärten offen
gelassen aber gesagt verlasst bitte das
Gelände nicht und dann Wochenmarkt auf
dem Rathausmarkt kleiner gemacht
derzeit läuft die Suche weiter und viele
hier fragen sich inzwischen wie das Tier
denn eigentlich in den Wald von
Kleinmachnow kommen konnte
ja das ist die entscheidende Frage und
die Antwort darauf wird noch ein
bisschen auf sich warten lassen aber
vielleicht erfahren wir gleich schon
mehr in wenigen Minuten um genau 13 Uhr
gibt es eine Pressekonferenz dort in
Kleinmachnow wir werden Sie live
übertragen also in fünf Minuten geht es
los nutzen wir die Zeit bis dahin noch
mit wie ich vorhin schon mal angedeutet
habe Florian Eiserloh zu sprechen von
der Tierschutzorganisation VIER PFOTEN
hat
hallo Sie sind nicht in Berlin und auch
nicht in Brandenburg sondern sie sitzt
mit ihrer Auffangstation für Wildtiere
in Rheinland-Pfalz macht aber in der
Sache ja keinen Unterschied denn das
kann ja überall und immer passieren
erzählen Sie doch mal aus ihrem Alltag
wie ungewöhnlich oder für Sie vielleicht
ja auch gewöhnlich sind denn solche
Fälle
ja man glaubt es nicht für uns ist das
tägliche Alter
also wir haben oft Anrufe von Behörden
von Privatleuten wo es tatsächlich darum
geht solche Tiere aufzunehmen das sind
dann
notrettungsaktionen oder Leute aus dem
Zirkus die uns um Hilfe bitten aber
meistens Behörden weil es
Beschlagnahmungen sind und ähm wir haben
tatsächlich hier Fälle auch aktuelle
Fälle
mehrmals im Jahr um genau wo es um
Raubkatzen geht im Privathaltung und in
Deutschland was haben Sie denn momentan
sozusagen da
zurzeit haben wir einen ein Puma das war
eine ja eine ähnliche Geschichte der ist
zwar nicht frei rumgelaufen aber auch
sehr wahrscheinlich einfach legal in
Tschechien gekauft nach Deutschland
transportiert und wir haben ja schon
gehört dass die Situation hier in
Deutschland ein bisschen unbefriedigend
ist was die Gesetzlage angeht das ist
teilweise möglich ist als Privatmann
sich solche Tiere zu halten und genau
dieser Puma sollte in einem Wohnzimmer
groß werden mitten in der Stadt und der
der Halter ist mit dem spazieren
gegangen an der Leine und hat sich da
also wirklich nicht so Gedanken gemacht
dass diese Katze auch mal 100 Kilo
schwer sein könnte und vielleicht auch
gefährlich sein wird als derjenige der
das dann ausbaden muss haben sie doch
sicher eine ausgeprägte Meinung zu
diesen Fällen oder
ja das ist also es kann eigentlich nicht
sein dass in Deutschland
die Gesetzeslage so miserabel ist was
das angeht gerade was exotische Tiere
und gefährliche Tiere angeht und da
machen wir uns bei vier Pfoten auch
wirklich sehr stark für und plädieren
für eine Positivliste und einfach eine
stärkere Regelung
und auch es sollte gemeldet werden weil
dazu gibt es auch gerade noch eine Frage
hier über Youtube von Chaos Komet 1 der
dann nämlich diese Frage stellt die gibt
es keine Meldepflicht wenn man solche
Tiere privat hält doch natürlich diese
Tiere sind meldepflichtig das sind
gefährliche Tiere die muss man anmelden
und normalerweise bekommt man auch sonst
keine Genehmigung also das wird eher Amt
muss Bescheid wissen die
Naturschutzbehörde müssen Bescheid
wissen
aber nichtsdestotrotz kann man ja
einfach in das nächste Nachbarland
fahren sich auf einer Internetbörse das
Tier kaufen und das dann halt im
Kofferraum mitnehmen und letztes Jahr
hatten wir den Fall da ist ein Puma im
Twingo aus Tschechien nach Deutschland
transportiert worden und nur durch
Zufall hat eine Polizei Kontrolle den
Halter dann
aufgefasste dann angehalten und hat
mitbekommen dass da ein Puma in
Kofferraum sitzt also die das ist nicht
nicht schwer so ein Tier auch nach
Deutschland
illegal reinzuholen ja puh mal im
kleinen Wagen klingt lustig ist es
natürlich nicht was sind das für
Menschen die das machen was sind die
Beweggründe dafür ist das ein
Statussymbol findet man das mal eine
Zeit lang ganz ganz exotisch und was
passiert dann
ja das
man könnte natürlich das als eine
gewisse Schlag Mensch abstellen wer Geld
hat der kann sich auch ein teures Auto
leisten obwohl man es jetzt nicht
unbedingt braucht mit 400 Sachen über
die Autobahn zu fahren
aber das ist natürlich ein status symbol
ein gefährliches Tier zu haben darüber
Macht auszuüben sozusagen das zu
bändigen
das ist natürlich ein Reiz ähm und ja
also ich will jetzt nicht sagen dass die
ihr hier nicht einschalten aber oft
machen die sich darüber keine Gedanken
dass es tatsächlich oft zu tödlichen
Unfällen kommt und wenn ein Tier
ausbricht das auch Gefahr für die
Bevölkerung steht schauen wir uns
vielleicht das Video von diesem Tier
noch mal an Sie haben es ja auch gesehen
und können vielleicht mit mir jetzt live
noch mal kommentieren was lesen Sie aus
diesen Ausnahmen heraus wie sicher ist
es aus ihrer Sicht tatsächlich eine
Löwin und welchen Eindruck macht das
Tier auf Sie
ja anhand von der Videoaufnahme ist das
natürlich auch schwer zu beurteilen was
das sein könnte und solange das auch
noch nicht bestätigt worden ist von
anderen Stellen dass das tatsächlich da
in Berlin war und das ist eine Großkatze
ist würde ich mich ja auch gar nicht aus
dem Fenster leben wollen es könnte ein
Löwe sein es könnte ein Puma sein
aber das möchte ich jetzt gar nicht da
irgendwie drauf eingehen Tatsache ist
solange das nicht bestätigt worden ist
dass es kein Löwe oder Puma ist sollte
man die Sache ernst nehmen weil die
Tiere gefährlich sind genau wir haben es
vorhin ja schon mal thematisiert mit
Herrn Kern aber auch aus ihrer Sicht
noch mal ein Tier das jetzt verängstigt
in einer ungewohnten Situation ist sie
haben täglich mit solchen Tieren zu tun
was ist aus ihrer Sicht das übliche
welchen Instinkt hat dieses Tier
es wurde schon kurz angesprochen also
die Tiere
sind natürlich aus ihrem normalen
alltäglichen Umgebung jetzt rausgerissen
wir wissen ja nicht wo es herkommt was
die Hintergründe sind ob das aus
Privathaltung kommt aus dem Zirkus kommt
oder vielleicht sogar aus einem
illegalen Transport ne der irgendwie das
Tier freigelassen hat oder wo es
entkommen ist aber prinzipiell sind die
Tiere verunsichert und ängstlich und
nervös und
die man muss jetzt sich da darf ich das
nicht vorstellen dass das jetzt
blutrünstige Räuber sind die jeden
Menschen oder jedes Tier anfallen was in
der Nähe ist und was ich bewegt aber
prinzipiell muss man schon aufpassen das
sind Wildtiere schnelle Bewegungen
überhastete Bewegung laufende Tiere oder
Rennende Menschen das sind potenzielle
Beutetiere für diese Karnivoren für
diese Großkatzen
und man kann das schlecht einschätzen
wie das Tier sich verhalten würde wenn
es direkt vor einem Menschen auftaucht
also das ist
es ist definitiv eine gefährliche
Situation man sollte sich definitiv
jetzt nicht unbedingt in dieser Gegend
aufhalten und die Ruhe bewahren wenn das
einem direkt vor die Nase läuft nicht
wegräumen laufen
ja aber es einzuschätzen wie es sich
verhalten wird das ist ganz schwierig
schauen wir mal ganz kurz auf ein
Live-Bild dass wir vorlegen wollen ich
habe es vorhin ja schon gesagt die
Pressekonferenz dort vor Ort wird in
wenigen Minuten beginnen soll jetzt um
13 Uhr beginnt kann also sein dass jeden
Moment dort jemand vor die Mikrofone
tritt das ist jetzt ein Live Bilder aus
kleinen macht nur und sobald dort also
erste neue Informationen zu erfahren
sind geben mir auch live wieder dahin er
iserlow sie haben vorhin schon mal
gesagt Puma im Kofferraum dafür muss es
ja einen Markt geben wie sieht denn
dieser Markt tatsächlich aus wer bietet
sowas an
traurigerweise ist das ein sehr
lukrativer Markt und wenn man sich in
diesem Netzwerken auskennt und in diesem
gesellschaftschaften dann wird man auch
schnell feststellen dass in Europa ein
großer Absatzmarkt dafür hätte in
Osteuropa wird gezüchtet die Zucht ist
legal der Transport und der Handel in
Europa ist legal
und das
ist natürlich für viele ein sehr
lukratives Geschäft weil die Tiere hoch
gehandelt werden und das hat leider
globale Auswirkungen weil gerade auf dem
asiatischen Markt die traditionelle
chinesische Heilmedizin
diese Produkte die aus diesen Tieren
dann gewonnen werden sehr fragt das sind
Tiger war ein Tigerknochen daraus werden
Pillen Potenzmittel gemacht und das ist
ein Millionen Milliardengeschäft und da
kann man schon von mafiösen Strukturen
reden und wenn man sich vorstellt dass
man für über einen erlegten Tiger wenn
man den zerlegt 30 40.000 € einnehmen
kann dann kann man verstehen was was da
eventuell für kriminelle Machenschaften
hinten dran stecken
wenn Sie mit diesen Tieren zu tun haben
oder immer wieder mal einfangen oder
vielleicht werden ja auch Tiere zu Ihnen
gebracht was hören sie so was sagen die
Menschen huch das hatte ich mir alles
mal ganz anders vorgestellt der ist doch
größer und hungriger geworden oder ist
da Naivität drin was erleben Sie ja ganz
oft Naivität muss man leider sagen wenn
die Tiere klein sind
Jungtier Alter Babyalter sind die
natürlich putzig da kann man mit den
Spielen und Schmusen ähm teilweise
gewöhnen die sich ja auch an den
Menschen
aber das weiter denken erstens mal dass
die Wildtiere natürlich für eine für
eine Art gemäße Unterbringung für eine
Art gemäßes Leben ziemlich hohe
Ansprüche haben zweitens kostet das sehr
viel Geld ähm die Tiere haben hohe
Ansprüche an ihre Ernährung an ihre
Physiologie also die müssen sich bewegen
können um sich gesund entwickeln zu
können da braucht man einen ordentliches
Gehege und ein Gehege für einen Puma und
ein Löwen das kann man nicht vergleichen
mit einer Gartenvoliere
ein bisschen schnell mehrere
hunderttausend Euro die man dann die
Hand nehmen muss und das ist vielen
einfach nicht bewusst und vor allem weil
man halt leicht drankommt die Tiere in
Anführungsstrichen billig sind also man
kann für mehrere tausend drei 4000 Euro
kommen sie schon an Löwen dran und das
ist das gefährliche und wenn jemand mal
so eine Schnapsidee hat und das umsetzen
möchte und sich denkt da ja ich habe es
im Youtube gesehen die kann man ja im
Wohnzimmer halten dann ist sowas mal
schnell umgesetzt leider wie finanzieren
Sie sich denn als diejenigen die das
dann wieder ausbaden müssen was andere
da verfügen
ja das ist nicht einfach also wir haben
leider keine großen Unterstützung von
unserer Bundesregierung für solche Fälle
gerade was die exotischen Tiere betrifft
und wir sind davon da darauf angewiesen
dass wir Unterstützer von
Spendern und von Supportern haben die
unsere Arbeit unterstützen und die auch
wie wir mehr Tierwohl haben möchten und
halt auch stärkere und strengere Gesetze
für die Tiere in Deutschland umsetzen
möchten weltweit eigentlich umsetzen
möchten denn es ist schön gerade fragt
über Youtube ich würde versuchen diesen
Löwen anzufüttern ist das eine
realistische Option ich nehme mal nicht
an dass er es persönlich Anfüttern würde
aber um sozusagen diesen Löwen ausfindig
zu machen oder wenn der Hunger kommt sag
ich mal wie wie geht man da am besten
vor
ja der
Kollege aus dem Kölner Zoo hat das ja
auch schon kurz beantwortet also
Anfüttern es ist schwierig weil wenn man
nicht weiß wo sich das Tier aufhält
theoretisch braucht ihr mehrere Tage
lang auch nichts zu fressen die
verhungern nicht gleich wenn man sich
das natürlich Verhalten von diesen
Raubkatzen anguckt die können ohne
Probleme mehrere Tage ohne Essen durch
über die Runden kommen und jetzt in so
einer Situation ist das glaube ich auch
das Letzte woran das hier denkt ähm
jetzt ein Stück Rindersteak zu essen ähm
das ist alles ne sehr aufregende und
stressige Situation für das Tier und
dann die Frage natürlich was machen so
okay sie könnten ihn versuchen
anzulocken und sich da irgendwie auf die
Lauer legen und dann mit dem Narkose
Gewehr versuchen den zu immobilisieren
aber auch da Schwierigkeiten die Tiere
sind dann natürlich noch mehr gestresst
und gereizt wenn sie so ein Dartpfeil
abbekommen das tut weh bis das
Narkosemittel wirkt dauern dauert es ein
paar Minuten also auch da ist dann das
Risiko und die Gefahr noch mal erhöht
man möchte es hier nicht unbedingt
gleich erschießen das ist ja immer so
der der letzte Ausweg und ich hoffe
nicht dass das passieren wird
aber es ist nicht so ganz einfach also
es ist nicht so wie jetzt ein Hund
entlaufenden einfangen zu wollen das
muss man sich alles ein bisschen
komplizierter vorstellen wie geht man
denn davor auch sie haben da ja
Erfahrungen also natürlich will man
sozusagen erstmal mit Betäubung das
bestmögliche erzielen
in ganz praktisch gefragt steht jemand
sozusagen da mit dem Finger am Abzug
falls es schief geht und dann den
möglichen tödlichen Schuss zu setzen und
man versucht es erstmal mit anderen oder
wie wie funktioniert das in der Praxis
wie viel Zeit unbedingt ja also ähm der
tödliche Schuss ist leider um
Menschenleben zu schützen
das Mittel der der ersten Wahl also
auch wenn wir wirklich sehr
tierfreundlich sind auch wir sind hier
ausgerüstet mit mit scharfen Gewehren
weil
permanent diese Gefahr einfach da ist
also wenn Menschen Fehler machen und
andere Menschen in Gefahr kommen müssen
auch wir zu dieser schrecklichen
Wahl greifen und dann tödlichen Schuss
abgeben können
ja mit dem Narkosegewehr man hat es auch
schon gesagt die Distanz die Reichweite
sind nicht ist nicht sehr groß also man
schießt wenn man wirklich gut ist und
geübt ist 30 50 Meter weit mit diesen
Narkosegewehr
man muss es auch richtig treffen der
Fall muss richtig sitzen dass Narkose
Mittel muss richtig dosiert sein wenn
das Tier unter Adrenalin ist dann hat
man sowieso noch andere
ja Einwirkungen auf auf die Narkose also
da kann es sein dass er gar nicht in
Narkose fällt dann muss immer also ein
Backup muss definitiv da sein und es
reicht auch nicht aus dass die Polizei
mit ihrer Bewaffnung vor Ort ist man
braucht da schon kurskalibrige Waffen
weil es sind Tiere die haben Muskeln 150
kg schwer danke für diese Schilderung
bis hin im Moment geht's im kleinen
macht nur los hören wir uns an was dort
die Pressekonferenz an Neuigkeiten
bringt dann sind wir wieder da
ja guten Tag meine Damen und Herren ich
begrüße Sie alle recht herzlich in
Kleinmachnow zur Pressekonferenz
entlaufene Löwin in Kleinmachnow
zunächst will ich uns hier vorne
vorstellen zu meiner Rechten ist Frau
Schröder Pressesprecherin der
Polizeidirektion West und zu meiner
Linken ist Herr Scholz Ordnungsamt aus
dem Ordnungsamt der Gemeinde
Kleinmachnow und zuständig für die
Einsatzleitung mein Name ist Michael
Grubert ich bin der Bürgermeister der
Gemeinde Kleinmachnow
stand 13:10 Uhr kann ich Ihnen mitteilen
die Löwen ist noch nicht gesichtet
worden das heißt unsere Maßnahmen die
hier in Kleinmachnow stattfinden laufen
im Moment noch auf hohen Touren es wird
gemeinsam gesucht die Polizei und auch
andere Kräfte versuchen die Löwen zu
finden und ja heute Nacht klopfte die
Meldung auf und ich habe Frau Schröder
hier von der Polizei Direktion West die
uns jetzt zunächst einmal einleitend
erklären wird was wie das dann
vonstatten ging als dann plötzlich per
Video eine Löwen gesichtet wurde Frau
Schröder bitte
ja gegen 0 Uhr in der vergangenen Nacht
ist die Polizei tatsächlich über den
Notruf informiert worden über die
Sichtung eines wildtieres
sofort wurde ein Video übermittelt und
nach erster Sichtung sind wir von einer
Ernsthaftigkeit ausgegangen also dass es
sich tatsächlich um ein wild hier
handelt und entsprechend haben wir
sofortige Suchmaßnahmen und Maßnahmen
zum Schutz der Bevölkerung
eingeleitet ja wir sind in
Zusammenarbeit mit der Polizei Berlin
unter anderem mit polizeihubschraubern
vorgegangen haben 30 Funkstreifenwagen
der Polizei des Landes Brandenburg im
Bereich von Kleinmachnow Teltow und
Stahnsdorf im Einsatz gehabt und diese
Suchmaßnahmen halten bis zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt an noch in der Nacht haben wir
Unterstützung von Tierärzten Veterinären
und auch Jägern in Anspruch genommen
haben diese informiert und auch diese
sind bis zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt in
weiterer Abstimmung mit der Polizei an
den Maßnahmen beteiligt
ja
als dann gegen 6 Uhr
gut okay wieder tauschen als dann gegen
6 Uhr auch bei uns im Rathaus die
Meldung durchgedrungen sind mussten wir
ja entscheiden was wir machen und den
Abstimmung hier bei uns im Haus mit
Herrn Scholz haben wir als erstes
entschieden über aufzurufen dass man
natürlich wie es auch von der Polizei
empfohlen wurde dass man möglichst das
Haus nicht verlassen soll zum Spazieren
gehen und erst recht nicht zum Joggen in
dem Wald dass man mit seinen Haustieren
die man reinholen soll und wenn man mit
seinem Hund eine Runde drehen soll dann
den Hund Anleihen und wirklich zu kurz
wie möglich wir haben dann entschieden
dass die Kindergärten geöffnet bleiben
dass wir aber alle Kindergärten gebeten
haben die Kinder in Empfang zu nehmen
aber die Einrichtung egal zum kein
Spielplatz oder so nicht zu verlassen
sondern sich auf dem Gelände des
Kindergartens aufzuhalten denn wir
müssen ja das Leben geht ja weiter wir
müssen schon sehen dass wir die Kinder
betreuen können aber die werden auch
heute und wenn die Lage weiter anhält
auch morgen sicherlich nur in der
Einrichtung betreut werden
wir haben sind sehr sehr froh dass in
der letzten Woche die Schulferien
begonnen haben damit haben wir das
Problem der Schulkinder auf dem Weg zur
Schule ab 7 Uhr nicht gehabt wir haben
dann weiter den Rathausmarkt bei dem wir
donnerstags immer den Wochenmarkt haben
runtergefahren haben gesagt dass wir
also die Händler bitten so weit es
möglich ist ihr entweder ihre Stände
kleiner zu machen oder gar nicht zu
kommen wir informieren über unsere
Homepage über weitere Sachen und
haben auch unsere
jugendfreizeiteinrichtung die ein
kinderfeuer im Programm macht auch
gebeten Sachen im Hause zu machen oder
auch mit dem Bus nach Berlin zu fahren
und dort da war nämlich eine Aktivität
heute vor angesehen vorgesehen dort was
weiter wahrzunehmen ansonsten haben wir
das Rathaus offen gelassen sind weiter
Ansprechpartner herr Scholz ist mit aus
dem Ordnungsamt heraus Einsatz die
Einsatzleitung hier in Kleinmachnow wir
werden unser weiteres Vorgehen immer
zusammen mit der Polizei abstimmen und
können einfach nur sagen im Moment
wird mit Drohnen und mit
Wärmebildkameras weiter in einem Gebiet
im was ist das
nordöstlichen von Kleinmachnow gesucht
weil dort
die zuletzt die das die Löwen gesichtet
worden ist andere Meldungen in
Stahnsdorf oder in Berlin haben sich
bisher nicht bestätigt es gibt keine
Hinweise darauf dass dort das
Wildschwein die Löwin gesichtet worden
ist und wenn es irgendwelche später gibt
es ist nicht unser neues System der
wildschweinbejagung in klein machen und
Löwinnen einzusetzen sondern wir
versuchen das immer noch normal zu
machen und werden auch keinen Serengeti
Park einrichten um dann vielleicht somit
das Wildschwein Problem lösen zu können
sondern es ist schon eine ernste Lage
der wir uns bewusst sind zum heutigen
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt kann ich Ihnen
leider nur sagen immer noch nicht
gefunden
davon aus dass das Video echt ist es
gibt auch eine Bestätigung über die
Polizei das ist einen solchen
wildvorgang in klein machen nur gab
so dass ich klar sagen kann wir gehen
davon aus dass das Video echt ist
also erstmal noch mal zum Video
stand jetzt ist nicht davon auszugehen
dass das entschwundene oder dass das
gesuchte Wildtier möglicherweise andere
Tiere gerissen haben könnte
das ist also nicht gesichert
also wir können nur noch mal wir können
nur noch mal ergänzend sagen dass wir
auch zur Herkunft des Tieres bereits in
der Nacht
Ermittlungen durchgeführt haben das
heißt wir haben Zoos Tierparks und
weitere tierhaltereinrichtungen
überprüft und angefragt aus keinem
dieser angefragten Einrichtungen ist ein
Tier dieser Art verschwunden
dazu können wir keine Auskunft geben als
Polizei denn dazu liegen uns keine
Erkenntnisse vor
es gibt keinen Hinweis darauf dass es
ein gemeldetes Tier hier in der Region
geht ich weiß gar nicht ob es zulässig
ist so ein Tier zu halten ich glaube das
dürfte nicht zulässig sein und selber in
der Region Teltow klein machen
Stahnsdorf von keinem privat
also was wir hinzugezogen haben ist
einmal eine unsere Amtstierärztin die
also auch mit der Polizei nach Spuren
gesucht hat und da haben wir deshalb
können wir Ihnen klar sagen
augenblicklich auch an dem Standort wo
das Video wohl gedreht worden ist gibt
es keinen Hinweis auf Blut andere Sachen
Code oder so von einem Wildtier
Experten haben wir insoweit hingezogen
sind werden im Moment hinzugezogen und
zu untersuchen ist das wirklich echt das
Video und ich kann ihn im Moment sagen
augenblicklich gehen wir von der
Echtheit des Videos wirklich aus weil es
auch mehrere nicht nur eine Bestätigung
das Videos gibt es gibt noch zwei drei
andere Sachen die zusammen dazu führen
dass die Puzzleteile sind und damit
können wir sagen es handelt sich wohl um
ein echtes Tier ein echte Tier
eine eigene Wahrnehmung der Polizei
die also auch gemeldet hat etwas später
das
ein solches das dass es sich um ein Tier
handelt was in klein machen gefunden
wurde gesehen worden ist also es ist
nicht nur das Video was über Mitternacht
dann kam sondern es ist auch eine eigene
später wahrgenommene Wahrnehmung der
Polizei zweimal
die Sichtung des Tieres seitens der
eingesetzten Polizeibeamten erfolgte
auch in der Nacht
wenn Sie diesen Tier begegnen dann gehen
sie natürlich umsichtig bei der bei der
wahrname vor also wir bitten Sie einfach
sich zurückzuziehen Schutz zu suchen und
die Polizei unter dem Notruf 110 zu
informieren so dass wir die
Kommunikationswege bedienen können und
mit dem zuständigen Veterinäramt hier
weitere Entscheidungen treffen können
zum Umgang mit dem oder zur wahrnahme
mit dem Tier
es gibt eine gesicherte wahrnahme von
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zur Nachtzeit
nach dem Video
wir sind derzeit im Einsatz mit Kräften
der Polizei Direktion West und darüber
hinaus mit Kräften der
bereitschaftspolizeiabteilung das heißt
derzeit befindet sich eine
Einsatzhundertschaft im Einsatz darüber
hinaus suchen wir aus der Luft mit
Drohnen und polizeihubschraubern
weiterhin die Gebiete in Teltow
Stahnsdorf und klein machen nur ab
Bewegung nimmt denn das hier geht das
Richtung Berlin oder wohin
die Anzahl der Einsatzkräfte kann zu mir
ziehen Zeitpunkt nicht herausgegeben
werden es ständig aufwachsend und ein
ständiger wechselobjekt denn auch die
Polizei Berlin mit der wir im regen
Kontakt stehen ist im Grenzbereich zum
Bundesland Berlin auch im Einsatz
zu den Einsatzgebieten der Polizei
Berlin kann ich jetzt keine Auskunft
geben nur ist es ja Usus auch ganz
normal in der normalen Zusammenarbeit
zwischen den Polizeien der beiden
Bundesländer das im Grenzgebiet sich
ausgetauscht wird Zulage
die Feststellung zum Video und der
Einsatzort der uns heute Nacht
mitgeteilt wurde war der Richard
straussweg hier in Kleinmachnow
jetzt fangen wir mal hier vorne an bitte
seitens der Polizei sind keine
raubtierspezialisten im Einsatz
inwiefern Spezialisten jetzt
Veterinäramtes und der Jagdbehörden im
Einsatz sind könnte herr Robert
beantworten
wir können sagen dass wir unseren Jäger
aktiv unsere Jäger aktiviert haben und
dass die Jäger auch mit Munition
ausgestattet sind um dann einzuschreiten
ich kann an dieser Stelle auch ganz klar
sagen dass erste Ziel wenn es irgendwie
möglich ist ist das Tier einzufangen
gegebenenfalls mit Betäubungsmitteln
eine andere Maßnahme wird nur dann
getroffen werden im Einzelfall von dem
Polizisten oder den Polizisten vor Ort
wenn die eigen das eigene Leben oder
andere Leben gefährdet sind ansonsten
nicht ganz klar sagen die Zielrichtung
ist Einfangen des Tiers gegebenenfalls
Betäubung und auf ihre Frage kann ich
Ihnen sagen es gibt über den Einsatzort
der in der Nacht aufgefunden wurde ein
größeres Gebiet was auch im Moment
kontrolliert wird gibt es keinen anderen
Hinweis dahin gehend der bestätigt ist
dass das Tier dieses Gebiet verlassen
hat
ich kann Ihnen also nicht sagen wo das
Tier ist ich kann dir nur sagen wir
hinweisen den immer nachgegangen wird
haben sich nie bestätigt das heißt
augenblicklich gehen wir davon aus dass
ein größeres Gebiet um die
Rudolf-Breitscheid-Straße hin zur
Autobahn den Walter hin dass das Tier
sich noch in diesem Gebiet befindet und
da will ich auch mal klar sagen wir sehr
viele Leute unterwegs sind ist auch sehr
also eigentlich ein bisschen
unwahrscheinlich dass das Tier plötzlich
fünf Kilometer weiter an einem anderen
Ort in Zehlendorf plötzlich ist denn da
gibt es schon mittlerweile genug Leute
die in dem Gebiet suchen also das wir
gehen davon aus dass es ein es war ein
großes Gebiet muss man ganz klar sagen
weil auch dahinter gleich der Wald kommt
aber das ist an einem anderen Ortsteil
in klein machen oder Teltow aufgetaucht
ist kann ich nicht bestätigen
Moment versuchen wir wie Frau Schröder
auch gesagt hat wir haben zwei Drohnen
wir haben Wärmebildkameras wir haben
Jäger die also auch die einzelnen Punkte
aufsuchen
und Leute von der Polizei also fallen
aufstellen glaube ich ist eine Maßnahme
die in den nächsten ein zwei Tagen nicht
zielführend sein wird das heißt wir
versuchen es mit dem normalen Weg zu
finden und gerade das was sie auch hier
oben hören was sie auch in der Nacht
gehört haben mit Wärmebildkameras
erscheint wohl als der im Moment beste
Weg
also ich habe diese Spekulation nicht
Welt gesetzt nachdem ich heute Morgen
geweckt wurde und dann auch das Radio
angestellt wurde wurde bei Radio 1
gleich gesagt bevor ich überhaupt diesen
Gedanken hatte kein Wunder dass das Tier
in klein machen oh ähm gesichtet worden
ist wenn man sich die Bevölkerung der
anguckt dann kann man sich nur
vorstellen privat wird so ein Tier wenn
überhaupt in Brandenburg in klein machen
nur gehalten das war also bei Radio 1
den Sender den ich höre und damit war
die Spekulation bevor ich etwas gesagt
hatte schon im Raum also ich
wir haben nur das einzige was ich ihnen
klar sagen kann alles von der Polizei
von uns angefragte Bereiche zu Zirkus
was man so hat hat gibt keine
Verlustmeldung keine abgängige Meldung
einer Löwin
das ist das was sie ihm sagen kann
ich glaube schon
also wir befinden ich habe keine Ahnung
weiß ich nicht
ja ich kenne die bei die beiden Videos
die es gibt und ich kann Ihnen klar
sagen ich weiß es nicht ich bin auch
kein Experte würde mir auch also Alter
schwach würde ich sie nicht bezeichnen
die Löwin aber ansonsten weiß ich nicht
kann ich nicht sagen
also grundsätzlich gehen wir natürlich
jedem Hinweis nach wir gehen auch jedem
Bürger Hinweis nach und wenn wir von
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern Hinweise
bezüglich eines Aufenthaltes eines Löwen
in einem Privathaushalt bekommen können
Sie sich sicher sein gehen wir auch
diesen Hinweisen nach zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt kann diese Erkenntnis jedoch
nicht bestätigt werden
haben wir zum derzeitigen Zeitpunkt
nicht korrekt
also ich muss Ihnen klar sagen dass ich
heute morgen um 6 Uhr die Information
bekommen habe ich habe noch nicht
nachgeguckt weil das ist ich bin seit 14
Jahren Bürgermeister des mir noch nicht
vorgekommen ich werde gerne nachreichen
was die Sachen sind weiß ich aber
wirklich nicht ich weiß nicht was dann
passiert passieren wird ich würde sagen
aus meinem Gefühl heraus das ist
verboten für Privatpersonen Tiere sowas
zu halten und das was wir schon einmal
gesagt haben von offizieller irgendwie
Tier Zirkus Tierpark oder so gibt es
keine Informationen hier in der Region
dass ein Tier fehlt eine Löwen fehlt
also die Bevölkerung ist schon sehr sehr
reagiert angemessen es gibt keine Panik
es gibt auch keine irgendwelche ähm
Hysterie etwas ähnliches wir machen alle
darauf aufmerksam geht bedächtig um jobt
nicht im Wald lass den Wald außen vor
Fahrt auch nicht mit dem Fahrrad durch
den Wald macht alles ganz normal und es
gibt hier also bei uns im Rathaus waren
nicht übermäßig viele Angriffe von
Besorgung
die Anzahl der Anrufe kann ich Ihnen im
jetzigen Moment nicht bestätigen ich
kann oder betiteln ich kann Ihnen nur
sagen dass jedem Hinweis der eingegangen
ist der sich aber im wirklich unteren
Maße aufhält dass diesen Hinweisen
nachgegangen wird
dazu kann dazu kann ich keine Auskunft
geben
Herr Scholz wir machen die
Einsatzleitung sie haben hier die
Feuerwehr was ist
ja seitens der Gemeinde Kleinmachnow
wurde uns um gegen 8:15 Uhr heute morgen
die Einsatzleitung von der Polizei
übertragen daraufhin sind wir ja
ergänzend mit eigenen Kräften tätig
geworden sowohl vom Ordnungsamt der
Gemeinde klein machen als mit der
Feuerwehr diese Maßnahmen
beschränken sich hauptsächlich um die
den entsprechenden Bereich zu bestreifen
das heißt
gegebenenfalls nicht Kontakt zu dem Tier
zu erlangen um dann weitere Maßnahmen zu
erlangen und wie bereits schon genannt
haben weitere mögliche sichtungspunkte
mit dem Tier kein Ergebnis geführt also
wir können unabhängig von dem Video seit
heute morgen keine weiteren Standorte zu
dem möglichen Tier geben
noch eine Frage sind die Hinweise die
sie haben nur beschränkt auf die beiden
Videos und
wir haben es gehört ich glaube jetzt
wiederholte sich so ein bisschen die
entscheidenden Aussagen sind vor allem
die noch weiß man nicht wo die Löwin ist
man geht davon aus dass es eine Löwin
ist es gab einen Kontakt nicht nur mit
dem Video das also Passanten gefilmt
haben sondern eben auch mit der Polizei
die dieses hier auch gesehen hat man
versucht so weit wie möglich den Alltag
so zu gewährleisten so gut es eben geht
die Kitas bleiben auf die Kinder dürfen
aber nur auf dem Gelände bleiben um da
natürlich Sicherheit zu gewährleisten
und das Tier wird jetzt mit
Wärmebildkameras und Drohnen gesucht
abschließend noch einmal Florian
Eiserloh der mir hoffentlich noch
zugeschaltet ist wir haben vorhin schon
gesprochen sie haben auch die
Pressekonferenz gehört und da geht auch
die letzte Frage die hier noch haben an
sie wieso hoch sind denn die Chancen
einen entlaufen ist hier mit dem
Hubschrauber zu finden darian fragt über
Youtube mit Wärmebild müsste man das
doch eigentlich schnell möglich machen
wir haben hier mitbekommen dass das
Gebiet relativ groß ist ich habe mir es
auch auf der Karte nochmal schnell
angeguckt das ist natürlich alles sehr
bald nah und im Dickicht kann sich so
ein Tier gut verstecken das ist liegt in
der Natur dieser Tiere
und wenn das einige Quadratkilometer
groß ist
die Tiere sind mobil also wenn das jetzt
keine altes geprächtliches Tier ist was
irgendwie Probleme mit dem
Bewegungsapparat hat dann können die
auch am Tag einige Kilometer hinter sich
bringen
und vor allem wenn es gestresst ist und
den Menschen aus dem Weg gehen möchte
den Lärm aus dem Weg gehen möchte
also das wird nicht einfach das Tier
gerade in so einer Vegetation in so
einer dichten Vegetation aufzuspüren
wird definitiv nicht einfach und auch ja
sie haben vorhin viele spannende Sachen
gesagt das ist ein Schwarzmann gibt das
ist Privatleute gibt die diese Tiere von
wer weiß wo exportieren im Kofferraum
rüberbringen über die Grenze dass da
wirklich viel Geld mitgemacht und auch
verdient wird all das jetzt wissen wir
ja noch nicht das muss man ausdrücklich
dazu sagen was in diesem konkreten Fall
die Umstände sind die dazu geführt haben
dass dieses Tier da jetzt frei rumläuft
unabhängig aber davon und im Wissen
darum was sie vorhin geschildert haben
und ja in ihrer Auffangstation dort
täglich erleben was sagt Ihnen dieser
Fall und was ist aus ihrer Sicht wichtig
dass dieser Fall auch der Öffentlichkeit
jetzt noch mal klar macht
ja das ist leider ein
passender Fall für die Situation die wir
hier in Deutschland oder in Europa haben
auf der einen Seite das oft oder das der
Großteil der Bevölkerung gar nicht weiß
was hier in Deutschland möglich ist wenn
es zu Wildtieren geht Haltung von
exotischen von gefährlichen Tieren
dass viele nicht wissen wie wie groß und
und
ja lukrativ dieser Markt ist und wie wie
stark diese Kanäle tatsächlich gefragt
sind weltweit also dass da ein
Absatzmarkt für herrscht auch hier in
Deutschland das ist wichtig dass das
mal so ein bisschen ja ans Licht
gebracht wird und es ist viel
Aufklärungsarbeit notwendig und wir
haben ja auch selbst gesehen die
Reaktion auch von den Bürgermeister dann
auch von den Behörden selbst die sind
manchmal
sprachlos wenn die mitbekommen was da
eigentlich alles passiert
man ist sich gar nicht sicher gibt es
privat Haltung ja das gibt es
wo werden diese Tiere gehalten wie kommt
man an die Tiere ran wie einfach ist das
an diese gefährlichen Tiere ranzukommen
und da muss wirklich viel passieren und
da muss unsere Bundesregierung endlich
mal ein bisschen die Augen öffnen und
sich deren Gewahr werden dass
Deutschland hier rückständig ist und das
ist nicht nur um Tierschutz geht sondern
das ist auch um die Sicherheit der
Bevölkerung geht und gerade jetzt auch
in Corona mit den Pandemie Ereignissen
Infektionskrankheiten das spielt alles
ein bisschen mit rein und das sollte man
irgendwie nicht aus den Augen verlieren
und ja also wir als
Tierschutzorganisationen wir versuchen
uns da wirklich gut aufzustellen und und
und das lautstark an die
Behörden zu kommunizieren und vor allem
auch an die Politiker dass diese Themen
ernst genommen werden Zirkus
Privathaltung Positivlisten Handel das
ist
wirklich eine ja eine wichtige Sache und
die geht uns allen was er Florian
Eiserloh danke dass Sie sich die Zeit
genommen haben danke für diese Einblicke
die sie uns gegeben haben danke für
diese ganzen Erklärungen auch diesen
letzten Appell hoffen wir in diesem
konkreten Fall dass es glimpflich für
alle Beteiligten ausgeht dass meint die
Löwin aber eben auch alle Anwohner dass
dort nichts passiert und dieses Tier
bestmöglich im bestmöglichen Zustand
gefangen wird wie gesagt und dann ist
grundsätzlich sicher auch noch mal über
dieses Thema zu reden das haben wir hier
mit erstmal getan und beobachten
natürlich diesen Fall weiter danke für
Ihre Zeit danke euch an die Fragen die
uns gestellt hat dann die Aufmerksamkeit
und wir hoffen wir konnten möglichst
viel Licht in dieses Schatten dicke ich
dort bringen was momentan auf diesen
Feld passiert und was alles mit zu
wissen ist und berücksichtigt werden
muss danke bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss